hi it's Nina it's Monday afternoon
you're supposed to be at work but it's
holiday today it's a family day in
Canada so what kind of relaxing chilling
watching some TV pop star so this point
I brew some coffee I made too much
coffee so instead of dumping away I
decided to make some Frappuccino oh well
actually I wanted to make ice cap but
it's like bitumen ice cannot fit so okay
Pacino I'm gonna have some ice - cup of
ice one cup of coffee 1/3 of chocolate
syrup I might just add some organic
chuck cocoa powder and then instead of
using white sugar I'm going to add some
brown sugar using the Vitamix to blend
everything first two cups
- 3 tbsp one I should make it - 2 TSP of
cocoa powder for those of you who like
rip whipped cream you cannot directly on
the tongue I don't like I don't like so
very very copy yeah so you can make your
own instead of going up get it from the
store coffee shop make your own cheap
fast
this is great check-in them
yeah I think scammer okay thank you for
watching please like the video and leave
a comment below I'll see you next time
believe you have chocolate sample of
yours on your shirt oh my god what's
that well there's lots of little spots
that we wear - I don't know my sweater
your sweater is more Brown audience
which sweater is more brown-haired if
you guys want to see even a homemade
whipped cream yeah comment hi everyone
my name is Colette Oh Rhett I recommend
that you try out Evan Carmichael's
newsletters they've helped me to restart
my business and realize my passion which
is awesome
you